Past predictions of artificial intelligence
looked like this, or this.
AI is here, and those predictions haven’t
come to pass… at least not yet.
In the last decade, Artificial Intelligence
has found real world applications in everything
from hedge funds to beer brewing...
And far from destroying humanity or solving
all of its problems, experts question how
much farther AI can go from here.
Artificial intelligence is software that solves
problems-- it looks at a confusing situation,
ventures a guess about what’s going on and
learns from what happens when it acts.
“you could think of it almost like a giant
excel spreadsheet, where you’re running
statistics to try and find the best guess.
That’s Bloomberg Tech’s Ashlee Vance
Is this an apple?
Let’s run these calculations to see if the
computer thinks it’s an apple.”
The companies that are making the most use
out of AI today are companies like Facebook,
Google, Microsoft, and Amazon.
it's pretty basic stuff like recognizing your
face in a photo.
It's translating a menu on your Google phone.
It's using computer vision in a self-driving
car to see where other cars are and where
obstacles are.
The first real attempts to create artificial
intelligence were in the 1950s, with the creation
of neural networks -- software that can process
data with some of the pattern-recognition
capabilities that takes place in our brains.
But It wasn’t until 2006<where did this
date come from?
Might be better to fudge with what the QT
says: "the last decade" that AI started to
takeoff.
The internet finally supplied the kind of
data that these neural nets needed for sustenance,
huge volumes of images and text.
And that's what allowed all these AI algorithms
to take off.
Today AI systems can even beat humans at things
like trading stocks, or playing the board
game Go.
They’re in driverless cars and can help
identify tumors.
But it’s still limited.
A computer will still have a huge problem
with things that a baby or even an animal
can understand intuitively, like if a kid
sees a glass get tipped over a couple of times,
the child intuitively understand gravity.
//It would take a really long time to teach
a computer something like that.
Today’s AI still needs humans to occasionally
tell it, “yes you’re doing the right thing”
or “no, that doesn’t look right.”
the end goal of all of this is to create something
that’s called an AGI, which is an artificial
general intelligence, which would be an AI
that didn’t need a human to hold its hand
to tell it what to do.
There’s a lot of debate about when or *if*
we’ll ever see AGI.
But even the possibility has made skeptics
of people like Elon Musk and Bill Gates, who
warn that AI might end up automating so many
tasks that millions of humans could end up
without jobs; or lead to other, unforeseen
calamities.
We’re summoning the demon with AI